I'd like to get started today we're
gonna talk about GFS the Google file
system paper we read for today
and this will be the first of a number
of different sort of case studies we'll
talk about in this course about how to
be build big storage systems so the
larger topic is big storage the reason
is the storage is turned out to be a key
abstraction you might you know if you
didn't know already you might imagine
that there could be all kinds of
different you know important
abstractions you might want to use for
distributed systems but it's turned out
that a simple storage interface is just
incredibly useful and extremely general
and so a lot of the thought that's gone
into building distributed systems has
either gone into designing storage
systems or designing other systems that
assume underneath them some sort of
reasonably well behaved big just
distributed storage system so we're
going to care a lot about how the you
know how to design a good interface to a
big storage system and how to design the
innards of the storage system so it has
good behavior you know of course that's
why we're reading this paper just to get
a start on that the this paper also
touches on a lot of themes that will
come up a lot in a tube for parallel
performance fault tolerance replication
and consistency and this paper is as
such things go reasonably
straightforward and easy to understand
it's also a good systems paper it sort
of talks about issues all the way from
the hardware to the software that
ultimately uses the system and it's a
successful real world design so it says
you know academic paper published in an
academic conference but it describes
something that really was successful and
used for a long time in the real world
so we sort of know that we're talking
about something that is it's a good a
good useful design okay so before I'm
gonna talk about GFS I want to sort of
talk about the space of distributed
storage systems a little bit
set the scene so first why is it hard
it's actually a lot to get right but for
a 2/4 there's a particular sort of
narrative that's gonna come up quite a
lot for many systems often the starting
point for people designing these sort of
big distributed systems or big storage
systems is they want to get huge
aggregate performance be able to harness
the resources of hundreds of machines in
order to get a huge amount of work done
so the sort of starting point is often
performance and you know if you start
there a natural next thought is well
we're gonna split our data over a huge
number of servers in order to be able to
read many servers in parallel so we're
gonna get and that's often called
sharding if you shard over many servers
hundreds or thousands of servers you're
just gonna see constant faults right if
you have thousands of servers there's
just always gonna be one down so we
defaults are just every day every hour
occurrences and we need automatic
weekend of humans involved and fixing
this fault we need automatic
fault-tolerant systems so that leads to
fault tolerance the among the most
powerful ways to get fault tolerance is
with replication just keep two or three
or whatever copies of data one of them
fails you can use another one so we want
to have tolerance that leads to
replication if you have replication two
copies the data then you know for sure
if you're not careful they're gonna get
out of sync and so what you thought was
two replicas of the data where you could
use either one interchangeably to
tolerate faults if you're not careful
what you end up with is two almost
identical replicas of the data that's
like not exactly replicas at all and
what you get back depends on which one
you talk to so that's starting to maybe
look a little bit
tricky for applications to use so if we
have replication we risk weird
inconsistencies of course clever design
you can get rid of inconsistency and
make the data look very well-behaved but
if you do that it almost always requires
extra work and extra sort of chitchat
between all the different servers and
clients in the network that reduces
performance so if you want consistency
you pay for with low performance I which
is of course not what we originally
hoping for of course this is an absolute
you can build very high performance
systems but nevertheless there's this
sort of inevitable way that the design
of these systems play out and it results
in a tension between the original goals
of performance and the sort of
realization that if you want good
consistency you're gonna pay for it and
if you don't want to pay for it then you
have to suffer with sort of anomalous
behavior sometimes I'm putting this up
because we're gonna see this this loop
many times for many of the systems we
look we look at people are we're rarely
willing to or happy about paying the
full cost of very good consistency ok so
you know with brought a consistency I'll
talk more later in the course about more
exactly what I mean by good consistency
but you can think of strong consistency
or good consistency as being we want to
build a system whose behavior to
applications or clients looks just like
you'd expect from talking to a single
server all right we're gonna build you
know systems out of hundreds of machines
but a kind of ideal strong consistency
model would be what you'd get if there
was just one server with one copy of the
data doing one thing at a time so this
is kind of a strong
consistency kind of intuitive way to
think about strong consistency so you
might think you have one server we'll
assume that's a single-threaded server
and that it processes requests from
clients one at a time and that's
important because there may be lots of
clients sending concurrently requests
into the server and see some current
requests it picks one or the other to go
first and excuse that request to
completion then excuse the nets so for
storage servers or you know the server's
got a disk on it and what it means to
process a request is it's a write
request you know which might be writing
an item or may be increment and I mean
incrementing an item if it's a mutation
then we're gonna go and we have some
table of data and you know maybe index
by keys and values and we're gonna
update this table and if the request
comes in and to read we're just gonna
you know pull the write data out of the
table one of the rules here that sort of
makes this well-behaved is that each is
that the server really does execute in
our simplified model excuse to request
one at a time and that requests see data
that reflects all the previous
operations in order so if a sequence of
writes come in and the server process
them in some order then when you read
you see the sort of you know value you
would expect if those writes that
occurred one at a time the behavior this
is still not completely straightforward
there's some you know there's some
things that you have to spend at least a
second thinking about so for example if
we have a bunch of clients and client
one issues a write of value X and wants
it to set it to one and at the same time
client two issues the right of the same
value but wants to set it to a different
the same key but wants to set it to a
different value right
something happens let's say client three
reads and get some result or client
three after these writes complete reads
get some result client four
reads X and get some also gets a result
so what results should the two clients
see yeah
well that's a good question so these
what I'm assuming here is that client
one inclined to launch these requests at
the same time so if we were monitoring
the network we'd see two requests
heading to the server at the same time
and then sometime later the server would
respond to them
so there's actually not enough here to
be able to say whether the client would
receipt would process the first request
first which order there's not enough
here to tell which order the server
processes them in and of course if it
processes this request first then that
means or it processes the right with
value to second and that means that
subsequent reads have to see to where is
it the server happened to process this
request first and this one's second that
means the resulting value better be one
and these these two requests and see
what so I'm just putting this up to sort
of illustrate that even in a simple
system there's ambiguity you can't
necessarily tell from trace of what went
into the server or what should come out
all of you can tell is that some set of
results is consistent or not consistent
with a possible execution so certainly
there's some completely wrong results we
can see go by it you know if client 3
sees a 2 then client 4 I bet had better
see it too also because our model is
well after the second right you know
climb trees these are two that means
this right must have been second and it
still had better be it still has to have
been the second right one client 4 goes
to the date so hopefully all this is
just completely straightforward and just
as expected because it's it's supposed
to be the intuitive model of strong
consistency ok and so the problem with
this of course is that a single server
has poor fault tolerance right if it
crashes or it's disk dies or something
we're left with nothing and so in the
real world of distributed systems we
actually build replicated systems so and
that's where all the problems start
leaking in is when we have a second
copying data so here is what must be
close to the worst replication design
and I'm doing this to warn you of the
problems that we will then be looking
for in GFS all right so here's a bad
replication design we're gonna have two
servers now each with a complete copy of
the data and so on disks that are both
gonna have this this table of keys and
values the intuition of course is that
we want to keep these tables we hope to
keep these tables identical so that if
one server fails we can read or write
from the other server and so that means
that somehow every write must be
processed by both servers and reads have
to be able to be processed by a single
server otherwise it's not fault tolerant
all right if reads have to consult both
and we can't survive the loss of one of
the servers okay so the problem is gonna
come up well I suppose we have client 1
and client 2 and they both want to do
these right say one of them gonna write
one and the other is going to write two
so client 1 is gonna launch it's right
x1 2 both because we want to update both
of them and climb 2 is gonna launch it's
write X so what's gonna go wrong here
yeah yeah we haven't done anything here
to ensure that the two servers process
the two requests in the same order right
that's a bad design
so if server 1 processes client ones
request first it'll end up it'll start
with a value of 1 and then it'll see
client twos request and overwrite that
with 2 if server 2 just happens to
receive the packets over the network in
a different order it's going to execute
client 2's requests and set the value to
2 and then then it will see client ones
request set the value to 1 and now what
a client a later reading client sees you
know if client 3 happens to reach from
this server and client for happens to
reach from the other server then we get
into this terrible situation where
they're gonna read different values even
though our intuitive model of a correct
service says they both subsequent reads
hefty you're the same value and this can
arise in other ways you know suppose we
try to fix this by making the clients
always read from server one if it's up
and otherwise server two if we do that
then if this situation happened and four
why oh yeah both everybody reads might
see client might see value too but a
server one suddenly fails then even
though there was no right suddenly the
value for X we'll switch from 2 to 1
because if server 1 died it's all the
clients assistant server 2 no but just
this mysterious change in the data that
doesn't correspond to any right which is
also totally not something that could
have happened in this service simple
server model all right so of course this
can be fixed the fix requires more
communication usually between the
servers or somewhere more complexity and
because of the cost of inevitable cost
to the complexity to get strong
consistency there's a whole range of
different solutions to get better
consistency and a whole range of what
people feel is an acceptable level of
consistency in an acceptable sort of a
set of anomalous behaviors that might be
revealed all right any questions about
this disastrous model here
okay that's what you're talking about
GFS a lot of thought about doing GFS was
doing is fixing this they had better but
not perfect behavior okay so where GFS
came from in 2003 quite a while ago
actually at that time the the web you
know was certainly starting to be a very
big deal and people are building big
websites in addition there had been
decades of research into distributed
systems and people sort of knew at least
at the academic level how to build all
kinds of highly parallel fault tolerant
whatever systems but there been very
little use of academic ideas in industry
but starting at around the time this
paper was published big websites like
Google started to actually build serious
distributed systems and it was like very
exciting for people like me who were I'm
a kid I'm excited this to see see real
uses of these ideas where Google was
coming from was you know they had some
vast vast data sets far larger than
could be stored in a single disk like an
entire crawl copy of the web or a little
bit after this paper they had giant
YouTube videos they had things like the
intermedia files for building a search
index
they also apparently kept enormous log
files from all their web servers so they
could later analyze them so they had
some big big data sets they used both to
store them and many many disks to store
them and they needed to be able to
process them quickly with things like
MapReduce so they needed high speed
parallel access to these vast amounts of
data okay so what they were looking for
one goal was just that the thing be big
and fast they also wanted a file system
that was sort of global in the sense
that many different applications could
get at it one way to build a big storage
system is to you know you have some
particular application or mining you
build storage sort of dedicated and
tailored to that application and if
somebody else in the next office needs
big storage well they can build their
own thing
right but if you have a universal or
kind of global reusable storage system
and that means that if I store a huge
amount of data si you know I'm crawling
the web and you want to look at my
crawled web web pages because we're all
using we're all playing in the same
sandbox we're all using the same storage
system you can just read my files you
know maybe access controls permitting so
the idea was to build a sort of file
system where anybody you know anybody
inside Google could name and read any of
the files to allow sharing in order to
get a in order to get bigness and
fastness they need to split the data
through every file will be automatically
split by GFS over many servers so that
writes and reads would just
automatically be fast as long as you
were reading from lots and lots of
reading a file from lots of clients you
get high aggregate throughput and also
be able to for a single file be able to
have single files that were bigger than
any single disk because we're building
something out of hundreds of servers we
want automatic feel your recovery we
don't want to build a system where every
time one of our hundreds of servers a
fail some human being has to go to the
machine room and do something with the
server or to get it up and running or
transfers data or something well this
isn't just fix itself um there were some
sort of non goals like one is that GFS
was designed to run in a single data
center so we're not talking about
placing replicas all over the world a
single GFS installation just lived in
one one data center one big machine run
so getting this style system to work
where the replicas are far distant from
each other is a valuable goal but
difficult so single data centers this is
not a service to customers GFS was for
internal use by
applications written by Google engineers
so it wasn't they weren't directly
selling this they might be selling
services they used GFS internally but
they weren't selling it directly so it's
just for internal use and it was
tailored in a number of ways for big
sequential file reads and writes there's
a whole nother domain like a system of
storage systems that are optimized for
small pieces of data like a bank that's
holding bank balances probably wants a
database that can read and write an
update you know 100 byte records that
hold people's bank balances but GFS is
not that system so it's really for big
or big is you know terabytes gigabytes
some big sequential not random access
it's also that has a certain batch
flavor there's not a huge amount of
effort to make access be very low
latency the focus is really on
throughput of big you know multi
megabyte operations this paper was
published at s OSP in 2003 the top
systems academic conference yeah usually
the standard for papers such conferences
they have you know a lot of very novel
research this paper was not necessarily
in that class the specific ideas in this
paper none of them are particularly new
at the time and things like distribution
and sharding and fault tolerance were
you know well understood had to had to
deliver those but this paper described a
system that was really operating in in
use at a far far larger scale hundreds
of thousands of machines much bigger
than any you know academics ever built
the fact that it was used in industry
and reflected real world experience of
like what actually didn't didn't work
for deployed systems that had to work
and had to be cost effective also like
extremely valuable the paper sort of
proposed a fairly heretical view that it
was okay for the storage system to have
pretty
consistency we the academic mindset at
that time was the you know the storage
system really should have good behavior
like what's the point of building
systems that sort of return the wrong
data like my terrible replication system
like why do that why not build systems
return the right data correct data
instead of incorrect data now with this
paper actually does not guarantee return
correct data and you know the hope is
that they take advantage of that in
order to get better performance I'm a
final thing that was sort of interesting
about this paper is its use of a single
master in a sort of academic paper you
probably have some fault-tolerant
replicated automatic failure recovering
master perhaps many masters with the
work split open um but this paper said
look you know you they can get away with
a single master and it worked fine well
cynically you know who's going to notice
on the web that some vote count or
something is wrong or if you do a search
on a search engine now you're gonna know
that oh you know like one of 20,000
items is missing from the search results
or they're in the wrong order probably
not so there was just much more
tolerance in these kind of systems than
there would like in a bank for incorrect
data it doesn't mean that all data and
websites can be wrong like if you're
charging people for ad impressions you
better get the numbers right but this is
not really about that in addition some
of the ways in which GFS could serve up
odd data could be compensated for in the
applications like where the paper says
you know applications should accompany
their data with check sums and clearly
mark record boundaries that's so the
applications can recover from GFS
serving them maybe not quite the right
data
all right so the general structure and
this is just figure one in the paper so
we have a bunch of clients hundreds
hundreds of clients we have one master
although there might be replicas of the
master the master keeps the mapping from
file names to where to find the data
basically although there's really two
tables so and then there's a bunch of
chunk servers maybe hundreds of chunk
servers each with perhaps one or two
discs the separation here's the master
is all about naming and knowing where
the chunks are and the chunk servers
store the actual data this is like a
nice aspect of the design that these two
concerns are almost completely separated
from each other and can be designed just
separately with separate properties the
master knows about all the files for
every file the master keeps track of a
list of chunks chunk identifiers that
contain the successive pieces that file
each chunk is 64 megabytes so if I have
a you know gigabyte file the master is
gonna know that maybe the first chunk is
stored here and the second chunk is
stored here the third chunk is stored
here and if I want to read whatever part
of the file I need to ask the master oh
which server hole is that chunk and I go
talk to that server and read the chunk
roughly speaking all right so more
precisely we need to turns out if we're
going to talk about how the system about
the consistency of the system and how it
deals with false we need to know what
the master is actually storing in a
little bit more detail so the master
data
it's got two main tables that we care
about it's got one table that map's file
name to an array of chunk IDs or chunk
handles this just tells you where to
find the data or what the what the
identifiers are the chunks are so it's
not much yet you can do with a chunk
identifier but the master also happens
to have a a second table that map's
chunk handles each chunk handle to a
bunch of data about that chunk so one is
the list of chunk servers that hold
replicas of that data each chunk is
stored on more than one chunk server so
it's a list chunk servers every chunk
has a current version number so this
master has a remembers the version
number for each chunk all rights for a
chunk have to be sequence ooh the chunks
primary it's one of the replicas so
master remembers the rich chunk servers
the primary and there's also that
primary is only allowed to be primary
for a certain least time so the master
remembers the expiration time of the
lease this stuff so far it's all in RAM
and the master so just be gone if the
master crashed so in order that you'd be
able to reboot the master and not forget
everything about the file system the
master actually stores all of this data
on disk as well as in memory so reads
just come from memory but writes to at
least the parts of this data that had to
be reflected on this writes have to go
to the disk so and the way it actually
managed that is that there's all
the master has a log on disk and every
time it changes the data it appends an
entry to the log on disk and checkpoint
so some of this stuff actually needs to
be on disk and some doesn't it turns out
I'm guessing a little bit here but
certainly the array of chunk handles has
to be on disk and so I'm gonna write env
here for non-volatile meaning it it's
got to be reflected on disk the list of
chunk servers it turns out doesn't
because the master if it reboots talks
to all the chunk servers and ask them
what chunks they have so this is I
imagine not written to disk the version
number any guesses written to disk not
written to disk requires knowing how the
system works I'm gonna vote written to
disk non-volatile we can argue about
that later when we talk about how system
works identity the primary it turns out
not almost certainly not written to disk
so volatile and the reason is the master
is um reboots and forgets therefore
since it's volatile forgets who the
primary is for a chunk it can simply
wait for the 62nd lease expiration time
and then it knows that absolutely no
primary will be functioning for this
chunk and then it can designate a
different primary safely and similarly
the lease expiration stuff is volatile
so that means that whenever a file is
extended with a new chunk goes to the
next 64 megabyte boundary or the version
number changes because the new primary
is designated that means that the master
has to first append a little record to
his log basically saying oh I just added
a such-and-such a chunk to this file or
I just changed the version number so
every time I change is one of those that
needs to writes right it's disk so this
is paper doesn't talk about this
much but you know there's limits the
rate at which the master can change
things because you can only write your
disk however many times per second and
the reason for using a log rather than a
database you know some sort of b-tree or
hash table on disk is that you can
append to a log very efficiently because
you only need you can take a bunch of
recent log records they need to be added
and sort of write them all on a single
write after a single rotation to
whatever the point in the disk is that
contains the end of the log file whereas
if it were a sort of b-tree reflecting
the real structure of this data then you
would have to seek to a random place in
the disk and do a little right so the
log makes a little bit faster to write
there to reflect operations on to the
disk however if the master crashes and
has to reconstruct its state you
wouldn't want to have to reread its log
file back starting from the beginning of
time from when the server was first
installed you know a few years ago so in
addition the master sometimes
checkpoints its complete state to disk
which takes some amount of time seconds
maybe a minute or something and then
when it restarts what it does is goes
back to the most recent checkpoint and
plays just the portion of a log that
sort of starting at the point in time
when that check one is created any
questions about the master data okay
so with that in mind I'm going to lay
out the steps in a read and the steps in
the right
where all this is heading is that I then
want to discuss you know for each
failure I can think of why does the
system or does the system act directly
after that failure um but in order to do
that we need to understand the data and
operations in the data okay so if
there's a read the first step is that
the client and what a read means that
the application has a file name in mind
and an offset in the file that it wants
to read some data front so it sends the
file name and the offset to the master
and the master looks up the file name in
its file table and then you know each
chunk is 64 megabytes who can use the
offset divided by 64 megabytes to find
which chunk and then it looks at that
chunk in its chunk table finds the list
of chunk servers that have replicas of
that data and returns that list to the
client so the first step is so you know
the file name and the offset the master
and the master sends the chunk handle
let's say H and the list of servers so
now we have some choice we can ask any
one of these servers pick one that's and
the paper says that clients try to guess
which server is closest to them in the
network maybe in the same rack and send
the read request to that to that replica
the client actually caches
cassia's this result so that if it reads
that chunk again and indeed the client
might read a given chunk in you know one
megabyte pieces or 64 kilobyte pieces or
something so I may end up reading the
same chunk different points successive
regions of a chunk many times and so
caches which server to talk to you for
giving chunks so it doesn't have to keep
beating on the master asking the master
for the same information over and over
now the client talks to one of the chunk
servers tells us a chunk handling offset
and the chunk servers store these chunks
each chunk in a separate Linux file on
their hard drive in a ordinary Linux
file system and presumably the chunk
files are just named by the handle so
all the chunk server has to do is go
find the file with the right name you
know I'll give it that
entire chunk and then just read the
desired range of bytes out of that file
and return the data to the client I hate
question about how reads operate can I
repeat number one the step one is the
application wants to read it a
particular file at a particular offset
within the file a particular range of
bytes in the files and one thousand two
two thousand and so it just sends a name
of the file and the beginning of the
byte range to the master and then the
master looks a file name and it's file
table to find the chunk that contains
that byte range for that file so good
[Music]
so I don't know the exact details my
impression is that the if the
application wants to read more than 64
megabytes or even just two bytes but
spanning a chunk boundary that the
library so the applications linked with
a library that sends our pcs to the
various servers and that library would
notice that the reads spanned a chunk
boundary and break it into two separate
reads and maybe talk to the master I
mean it may be that you could talk to
the master once and get two results or
something but logically at least it two
requests to the master and then requests
to two different chunk servers yes well
at least initially the client doesn't
know for a given file
what chunks need what chunks well it can
calculate it needs the seventeenth chunk
but but then it needs to know what chunk
server holds the seventeenth chunk of
that file and for that it certainly
needs for that it needs to talk to the
master okay so all right did I'm not
going to make a strong claim about which
of them decides that it was the
seventeenth chunk in the file but it's
the master that finds the identifier of
the handle of the seventeenth chunk in
the file looks that up in its table and
figures out which chunk servers hold
that chunk yes
how does that or you mean if the if the
client asks for a range of bytes that
spans a chunk boundary yeah so the the
well you know the client will ask that
well the clients linked with this
library is a GFS library that noticed
how to take read requests apart and put
them back together and so that library
would talk to the master and the master
would tell it well well you know chunk
seven is on this server and chunk eight
is on that server and then why the
library would just be able to say oh you
know I need the last couple bites of
chunk seven and the first couple bites
of chunk eight and then would fetch
those put them together in a buffer and
return them to the calling application
well the master tells it about chunks
and the library kind of figures out
where it should look in a given chunk to
find the date of the application wanded
the application only thinks in terms of
file names and sort of just offsets in
the entire file in the library and the
master conspire to turn that into chunks
yeah
sorry let me get closer here you see
again so the question is does it matter
which chunk server you reach room so you
know yes and no notionally they're all
supposed to be replicas in fact as you
may have noticed or as we'll talk about
they're not you know they're not
necessarily identical and applications
are supposed to be able to tolerate this
but the fact is that you make a slightly
different data depending on which
replicas you read yeah so the paper says
that clients try to read from the chunk
server that's in the same rack or on the
same switch or something all right so
that's reads
the rights are more complex and
interesting now the application
interface for rights is pretty similar
there's just some call some library you
call to mate you make to the gfs client
library saying look here's a file name
and a range of bytes I'd like to write
and the buffer of data that I'd like you
to write to that that range actually let
me let me backpedal I only want to talk
about record of pens and so I'm going to
praise this the client interface as the
client makes a library call that says
here's a file name and I'd like to
append this buffer of bytes to the file
I said this is the record of pens that
the paper talks about so again the
client asks the master look I want to
append sends a master requesting what I
would like to pen to this named file
please tell me where to look for the
last chunk in the file because the
client may not know how long the file is
if lots of clients are opinion to the
same file because we have some big file
this logging stuff from a lot of
different clients may be you know no
client will necessarily know how long
the file is and therefore which offset
or which chunk it should be appending to
so you can ask the master please tell me
about the the server's that hold the
very last chunk
current chunk in this file so
unfortunately now the writing if you're
reading you can read from any up-to-date
replica for writing though there needs
to be a primary so at this point on the
file may or may not have a primary
already designated by the master so we
need to consider the case of if there's
no primary already and all the master
knows well there's no primary so so one
case is no primary
in that case the master needs to find
out the set of chunk servers that have
the most up-to-date copy of the chunk
because know if you've been running the
system for a long time due to failures
or whatever there may be chunk servers
out there that have old copies of the
chunk from you know yesterday or last
week that I've been kept up to kept up
to date because maybe that server was
dead for a couple days and wasn't
receiving updates so there's you need to
be able to tell the difference between
up-to-date copies of the chunk and non
up-to-date so the first step is to find
you know find up-to-date this is all
happening in the master because the
client has asked the master told the
master look I want up end of this file
please tell me what chunk service to
talk to so a part of the master trying
to figure out what chunk servers the
client should talk to you
so when we finally find up-to-date
replicas and what update means is a
replica whose version of the chunk is
equal to the version number that the
master knows is the most up-to-date
version number it's the master that
hands out these version numbers the
master remembers that oh for this
particular chunk you know the trunk
server is only up to date if it has
version number 17 and this is why it has
to be non-volatile stored on disk
because if if it was lost in a crash and
there were chunk servers holding stale
copies of chunks the master wouldn't be
able to distinguish between chunk
servers holding stale copies of a chunk
from last week and a chunk server that
holds the copy of the chunk that was
up-to-date as of the crash that's why
the master members of version number on
disk yeah
if you knew you were talking to all the
chunk servers okay so the observation is
the master has to talk to the chunk
servers anyway if it reboots in order to
find which chunk server holds which
chunk because the master doesn't
remember that so you might think that
you could just take the maximum you
could just talk to the chunk servers
find out what trunks and versions they
hold and take the maximum for a given
chunk overall the responding chunk
servers and that would work if all the
chunk servers holding a chunk responded
but the risk is that at the time the
master reboots maybe some of the chunk
servers are offline or disconnected or
whatever themselves rebooting and don't
respond and so all the master gets back
is responses from chunk servers that
have last week's copies of the block and
the chunk servers that have the current
copy haven't finished rebooting or
offline or something so ok oh yes if if
the server's holding the most recent
copy are permanently dead if you've lost
all copies all of the most recent
version of a chunk then yes
No
okay so the question is the master knows
that for this chunk is looking for
version 17
supposing it finds no chunk server you
know and it talks to the chunk servers
periodically to sort of ask them what
chunks do you have what versions you
have supposing it finds no server with
chunk 17 with version 17 for this this
chunk then the master will either say
well either not respond yet and wait or
it will tell the client look I can't
answer that try again later and this
would come up like there was a power
failure in the building and all the
server's crashed and we're slowly
rebooting the master might come up first
and you know some fraction of the chunk
servers might be up and other ones would
reboot five minutes from now but so we
ask to be prepared to wait and it will
wait forever because you don't want to
use a stale version of that of a chunk
okay so the master needs to assemble the
list of chunk servers that have the most
recent version the master knows the most
recent versions stored on disk each
chunk server along with each chunk as
you pointed out also remembers the
version number of the chunk that it's
stores so that when chunk slivers
reported into the master saying look I
have this chunk the master can ignore
the ones whose version does not match
the version the master knows is the most
recent okay so remember we were the
client want to append the master doesn't
have a primary it figures out maybe you
have to wait for the set of chunk
servers that have the most recent
version of that chunk it picks a primary
so I'm gonna pick one of them to be the
primary and the others to be secondary
servers
among the replicas set at the most
recent version the master then
increments
the version number and writes that to
disk so it doesn't forget it the crashes
and then it sends the primary in the
secondaries and that's each of them a
message saying look for this chunk
here's the primary here's the
secondaries you know recipient maybe one
of them and here's the new version
number so then it tells primary
secondaries this information plus the
version number the primaries and
secondaries
alright the version number to disk so
they don't forget because you know if
there's a power failure or whatever they
have to report in to the master with the
actual version number they hold yes
that's a great question
so I don't know there's hints in the
paper that I'm slightly wrong about this
so the paper says I think your question
was explaining something to me about the
paper the paper says if the master
reboots and talks to chunk servers and
one of the chunk servers reboot reports
a version number that's higher than the
version number the master remembers the
master assumes that there was a failure
while it was assigning a new primary and
adopts the new the higher version number
that it heard from a chunk server so it
must be the case that in order to handle
a master crash at this point that the
master writes its own version number to
disk after telling the primaries there's
a bit of a problem here though because
if the was that is there an ACK
all right so maybe the master tells the
primaries and backups and that their
primaries and secondaries if they're a
primary secondary tells him the new
version number waits for the AK and then
writes to disk or something unsatisfying
about this I don't believe that works
because of the possibility that the
chunk servers with the most recent
version numbers being offline at the
time the master reboots we wouldn't want
the master the master doesn't know the
current version number it'll just accept
whatever highest version number adheres
which could be an old version number all
right so this is a an area of my
ignorance I don't really understand
whether the master update system version
number on this first and then tells the
primary secondary or the other way
around and I'm not sure it works either
way okay but in any case one way or
another the master update is version
number tells the primary secondary look
your primaries and secondaries here's a
new version number and so now we have a
primary which is able to accept writes
all right that's what the primaries job
is to take rights from clients and
organize applying those rights to the
various chunk servers and you know the
reason for the version number stuff is
so that the master will recognize the
which servers have this new you know the
master hands out the ability to be
primary for some chunk server we want to
be able to recognize if the master
crashes you know that it was that was
the primary that only that primary and
it secondaries which were actually
processed which were in charge of
updating that chunk that only those
primaries and secondaries are allowed to
be chunk servers in the future and the
way the master does this is with this
version number logic
okay so the master tells the primaries
and secondaries that there it they're
allowed to modify this block it also
gives the primary a lease which
basically tells the primary look you're
allowed to be primary for the next sixty
seconds after sixty Seconds you have to
stop and this is part of the machinery
for making sure that we don't end up
with two primaries I'll talk about a bit
later okay so now we were primary now
the master tells the client who the
primary and the secondary czar and at
this point we're we're executing in
figure two in the paper the client now
knows who the primary secondaries are in
some order or another and the paper
explains a sort of clever way to manage
this in some order or another the client
sends a copy of the data it wants to be
appended to the primary in all the
secondaries and the primary in the
secondaries write that data to a
temporary location it's not appended to
the file yet after they've all said yes
we have the data the client sends a
message to the primary saying look you
know you and all the secondaries have
the data I'd like to append it for this
file
the primary maybe is receiving these
requests from lots of different clients
concurrently it picks some order execute
the client request one at a time and for
each client a pen request the primary
looks at the offset that's the end of
the file the current end of the current
chunk makes sure there's enough
remaining space in the chunk and then
tells then writes the clients record to
the end of the current chunk and tells
all the secondaries to also write the
clients data to the end to the same
offset the same offset in their chunks
all right so the primary picks an offset
all the replicas including the primary
are told to write
the new appended record at at offset the
secondary's they may do it they may not
do it I'm either run out of space maybe
they crashed maybe the network message
was lost from the primary so if a
secondary actually wrote the data to its
disk at that offset it will reply yes to
the primary if the primary collects a
yes answer from all of the secondaries
so if they all of all of them managed to
actually write and reply to the primary
saying yes I did it then the primary is
going to reply reply success to the
client if the primary doesn't get an
answer from one of the secondaries or
the secondary reply sorry something bad
happened I ran out of disk space my disk
I don't know what then the primary
replies no to the client and the paper
says oh if the client gets an error like
that back in the primary the client is
supposed to reissue the entire append
sequence starting again talking to the
master to find out the most grease the
chunk at the end of the file
I want to know the client supposed to
reissue the whole record append
operation ah you would think but they
don't so the question is jeez you know
the the primary tells all the replicas
to do the append yeah maybe some of them
do some of them don't
right if some of them don't then we
apply an error to the client so the
client thinks of the append in happen
but those other replicas where the pen
succeeded they did append so now we have
replicas donor the same data one of them
the one that returned in error didn't do
the append and the ones they returned
yes did do the append so that is just
the way GFS works
yeah so if a reader then reads this file
they depending on what replica they be
they may either see the appended record
or they may not if the record append
but if the record append succeeded if
the client got a success message back
then that means all of the replicas
appended that record at the same offset
if the client gets a no back then zero
or more of the replicas may have
appended the record of that all set and
the other ones not so the client got to
know then that means that some replicas
maybe some replicas have the record and
some don't so what you which were
roughly read from you know you may or
may not see the record yeah
oh that all the replicas are the same
all the secondaries are the same version
number so the version number only
changes when the master assigns a new
primary which would ordinarily happen
and probably only happen if the primary
failed so what we're talking about is is
replicas that have the fresh version
number all right and you can't tell from
looking at them that they're missing
that the replicas are different but
maybe they're different and the
justification for this is that yeah you
know maybe the replicas don't all have
that the appended record but that's the
case in which the primary answer no to
the clients and the client knows that
the write failed and the reasoning
behind this is that then the client
library will reissue the append so the
appended record will show up you know
eventually the a pendel succeed you
would think because the client I'll keep
reissuing it until succeeds and then
when it succeeds that means there's
gonna be some offset you know farther on
in the file where that record actually
occurs in all the replicas as well as
offsets preceding that word only occurs
in a few of the replicas yes
oh this is a great question
the exact path that the right data takes
might be quite important with respect to
the underlying network and the paper
somewhere says even though when the
paper first talks about it he claims
that the client sends the data to each
replica in fact later on it changes the
tune and says the client sends it to
only the closest of the replicas and
then the replicas then that replica
forwards the data to another replica
along I sort of chained until all the
replicas had the data and that path of
that chain is taken to sort of minimize
crossing bottleneck inter switch links
in a data center yes the version number
only gets incremented if the master
thinks there's no primary so it's a so
in the ordinary sequence there already
be a primary for that chunk the the
the the master sort of will remember oh
gosh there's already a primary and
secondary for that chunk and it'll just
it won't go through this master
selection it won't increment the version
number it'll just tell the client look
up here's the primary with with no
version number change
my understanding is that if this is this
I think you're asking a you're asking an
interesting question so in this scenario
in which the primaries isn't answered
failure to the client you might think
something must be wrong with something
and that it should be fixed before you
proceed in fact as far as I can tell the
paper there's no immediate anything the
client retries the append you know
because maybe the problem was a network
message got lost so there's nothing to
repair right you know now we're gonna
message got lost we should be
transmitted and this is sort of a
complicated way of retransmitting the
network message maybe that's the most
common kind of failure in that case just
we don't change anything it's still the
same primary same secondaries the client
we tries maybe this time it'll work
because the network doesn't
discard a message it's an interesting
question though that if what went wrong
here is that one of that there was a
serious error or Fault in one of the
secondaries what we would like is for
the master to reconfigure that set of
replicas to drop that secondary that's
not working and it would then because
it's choosing a new primary in executing
this code path the master would then
increment the version and then we have a
new primary and new working secondaries
with a new version and this not-so-great
secondary with an old version and a
stale copy of the data but because that
has an old version the master will never
never mistake it for being fresh but
there's no evidence in the paper that
that happens immediately as far as
what's said in the paper the client just
retries and hopes it works again later
eventually the master will if the
secondary is dead
eventually the master does ping all the
trunk servers will realize that and will
probably then change the set of
primaries and secondaries and increment
the version but only only later
the lease the leases that the answer to
the question what if the master thinks
the primary is dead because it can't
reach it right that's supposing we're in
a situation where at some point the
master said you're the primary and the
master was like painting them all the
service periodically to see if they're
alive because if they're dead and wants
to pick a new primary the master sends
some pings to you you're the primary and
you don't respond right so you would
think that at that point where gosh
you're not responding to my pings then
you might think the master at that point
would designate a new primary it turns
out that by itself is a mistake and the
reason for that the reason why it's a
mistake to do that simple did you know
use that simple design is that I may be
pinging you and the reason why I'm not
getting responses is because then
there's something wrong with a network
between me and you so there's a
possibility that you're alive you're the
primary you're alive I'm peeing you the
network is dropping that packets but you
can talk to other clients and you're
serving requests from other clients you
know and if I if I the master sort of
designated a new primary for that chunk
now we'd have two primaries processing
rights but two different copies of the
data and so now we have totally
diverging copies the data and that's
called that error having two primaries
or whatever processing requests without
knowing each other it's called squid
brain and I'm writing this on board
because it's an important idea and it'll
come up again and it's caused or it's
usually said to be caused by network
partition that is some network error in
which the master can't talk to the
primary but the primary can talk to
clients sort of partial network failure
and you know these are some of the these
are the hardest problems to deal with
and building these kind of storage
systems okay so that's the problem is we
want to rule out the possibility of
mistakingly designating too
I'm Aries for the same chunk the way the
master achieves that is that when it
designates a primary it says it gives a
primary Elyse which is basically the
right to be primary until a certain time
the master knows it remembers and knows
how long the least lasts and the primary
knows how long is least lasts if the
lease expires the primary knows that it
expires and will simply stop executing
client requests it'll ignore or reject
client requests after the lease expired
and therefore if the master can't talk
to the primary and the master would like
to designate a new primary the master
must wait for the lease to expire for
the previous primary so that means
master is going to sit on its hands for
one lease period 60 seconds after that
it's guaranteed the old primary will
stop operating its primary and now the
master can see if he doesn't need a new
primary without producing this terrible
split brain situation
oh so the question is why is designated
a new primary bad since the clients
always ask the master first and so the
master changes its mind then subsequent
clients will direct the clients to the
new primary well one reason is that the
clients cash for efficiency the clients
cash the identity of the primary for at
least for short periods of time even if
they didn't though the bad sequence is
that I'm the prime the master you ask me
who the primary is I send you a message
saying the primary is server one right
and that message is inflate in the
network and then I'm the master I you
know I think somebody's failed whatever
I think that primary is filled I
designated a new primary and I send the
primary message saying you're the
primary and I start answering other
clients who ask the primary is saying
that that over there is the primary
while the message to you is still in
flight you receive the message saying
the old primaries the primary you think
gosh I just got this from the master I'm
gonna go talk to that primary and
without some much more clever scheme
there's no way you could realize that
even though you just got this
information from the master it's already
out of date and if that primary serves
your modification requests now we have
to and and respond success to you right
then we have two conflicting replicas
yes
again you've a new file and no replicas
okay so if you have a new file no
replicas or even an existing file and no
replicas the you'll take the path I drew
on the blackboard the master will
receive a request from a client saying
oh I'd like to append to this file and
then well I guess the master will first
see there's no chunks associated with
that file and it will just make up a new
chunk identifier or perhaps by calling
the random number generator and then
it'll look in its chunk information
table and see gosh I don't have any
information about that chunk and it'll
make up a new record saying but it must
be special case code where it says well
I don't know any version number this
chunk doesn't exist I'm just gonna make
up a new version number one pick a
random primary and set of secondaries
and tell them look you are responsible
for this new empty chunk please get to
work the paper says three replicas per
chunk by default so typically a primary
and two backups
okay okay so the maybe the most
important thing here is just to repeat
the discussion we had a few minutes ago
the intentional construction of GFS we
had these record a pens is that if we
have three we have three replicas you
know maybe a client sends in and a
record a pen for record a and all three
replicas or the primary and both of the
secondaries successfully append the data
the chunks and maybe the first record in
the trunk might be a in that case and
they all agree because they all did it
supposing another client comes in says
look I want a pen record B but the
message is lost to one of the replicas
the network whatever supposably the
message by mistake but the other two
replicas get the message and one of
them's a primary and my other
secondaries they both depend of the file
so now what we have is two the replicas
that B and the other one doesn't have
anything and then may be a third client
wants to append C and maybe the remember
that this is the primary the primary
picks the offset since the primary just
gonna tell the secondaries look in a
right record C at this point in the
chunk they all right C here now the
client for be the rule for a client for
B that for the client that gets us error
back from its request is that it will
resend the request so now the client
that asked to append record B will ask
again to a pen record B and this time
maybe there's no network losses and all
three replicas as a panel record be
right and they're all lives there I'll
have the most fresh version number and
now if a client reads
what they see depends on the track which
replicas they look at it's gonna see in
total all three of the records but it'll
see in different orders depending on
which replica reads it'll mean I'll see
a B C and then a repeat of B so if it
reads this replica it'll see B and then
C if it reads this replica it'll see a
and then a blank space in the file
padding and then C and then B so if you
read here you see C then B if you read
here you see B and then C so different
readers will see different results and
maybe the worst situation is it some
client gets an error back from the
primary because one of the secondaries
failed to do the append and then the
client dies before we sending the
request so then you might get a
situation where you have record D
showing up in some of the replicas and
completely not showing up anywhere in
the other replicas so you know under
this scheme we have good properties for
for appends that the primary sent back a
successful answer for and sort of not so
great properties for appends where the
primary sent back of failure and the
records the replicas just absolutely be
different all different sets of replicas
yes
my reading in the paper is that the
client starts at the very beginning of
the process and asked the master again
what's the last chunk in this file you
know because it might be might have
changed if other people are pending in
the file yes
so I can't you know I can't read the
designers mind so the observation is the
system could have been designed to keep
the replicas in precise sync it's
absolutely true and you will do it in
labs 2 & 3 so you guys are going to
design a system that does replication
that actually keeps the replicas in sync
and you'll learn you know there's some
various techniques various things you
have to do in order to do that and one
of them is that there just has to be
this rule if you want the replicas to
stay in sync it has to be this rule that
you can't have these partial operations
that are applied to only some and not
others and that means that there has to
be some mechanism to like where the
system even if the client dies where the
system says we don't wait a minute there
was this operation I haven't finished it
yet so you build systems in which the
primary actually make sure the backups
get every message
if the first right abhi failed you think
the sea should go with the beers
well it doesn't you may think it should
but the way the system actually operates
is that the primary will add C to the
end of the chunk and the after V yeah I
mean one reason for this is that at the
time the right Percy comes in the
primary may not actually know what the
fate of B was because we met multiple
clients submitting a pen's concurrently
and you know for high performance you
want the primary to start the append for
B first and then as soon as I can got
the next stop set tell everybody did you
see so that all this stuff happens in
parallel you know by slowing it down you
could you know the primary could sort of
decide that B it totally failed and then
send another round of messages saying
please undo the right of B and there'll
be more complex and slower I'm you know
again the the justification for this is
that the design is pretty simple it you
know it reveals some odd things to
applications and the hope was that
applications could be relatively easily
written to tolerate records being in
different orders or who knows what or if
they couldn't that applications could
either make their own arrangements for
picking an order themselves and writing
you know sequence numbers in the files
or something or you could just have a if
application really was very sensitive to
order you could just not have concurrent
depends from different clients to the
same file right you could just you know
close files where order is very
important like say it's a movie file you
know you don't want to scramble
bytes in a movie file you just write the
Moot file you write the movie to the
file by one client in sequential order
and not with concurrent record depends
okay all right
the somebody asked basically what would
it take to turn this design into one
which actually provided strong
consistency consistency closer to our
sort of single server model where
there's no surprises I don't actually
know because you know that requires an
entire new complex design it's not clear
how to mutate GFS to be that design but
I can list for you lists for you some
things that you would want to think
about if you wanted to upgrade GFS to a
assistance did have strong consistency
one is that you probably need the
primary to detect duplicate requests so
that when this second becomes in the
primary is aware that oh actually you
know we already saw that request earlier
and did it or didn't do it and to try to
make sure that B doesn't show up twice
in the file so one is you're gonna need
duplicate detection another issues you
probably if a secondary is acting a
secondary you really need to design the
system so that if the primary tells a
secondary to do something
the secondary actually does it and
doesn't just return error right for a
strictly consistent system having the
secondaries be able to just sort of blow
off primary requests with really no
compensation is not okay so I think the
secondaries have to accept requests and
execute them or if a secondary has some
sort of permanent damage like it's disk
got unplugged by mistake this you need
to have a mechanism to like take the
secondary out of the system so the
primary can proceed with the remaining
secondaries but GFS kind of doesn't
either at least not right away
and so that also means that when the
primary asks secondary's to append
something the secondaries have to be
careful not to expose that data to
readers until the primary is sure that
all the secondaries really will be able
to execute the append so you might need
sort of multiple phases in the rights of
first phase in which the primary asks
the secondaries look you know I really
like you to do this operation can you do
it but don't don't actually do it yet
and if all the secondaries answer with a
promise to be able to do the operation
only then the primary says alright
everybody go ahead and do that operation
you promised and people you know that's
the way a lot of real world systems
strong consistent systems work and that
trick it's called two-phase commit
another issue is that if the primary
crashes there will have been some last
set of operations that the primary had
launched started to the secondaries but
the primary crashed before it was sure
whether those all the secondaries got
there copied the operation or not so if
the primary crashes you know a new
primary one of the secondaries is going
to take over as primary but at that
point the second the new primary and the
remaining secondaries may differ in the
last few operations because maybe some
of them didn't get the message before
the primary crashed and so the new
primer has to start by explicitly
resynchronizing with the secondaries to
make sure that the sort of the tail of
their operation histories are the same
finally to deal with this problem of oh
you know there may be times when the
secondaries differ or the client may
have a slightly stale indication from
the master of which secondary to talk to
the system either needs to send all
client reads through the primary because
only the primary is likely to know which
operations have really happened or we
need a least system for the secondaries
just like we have for the primary so
that it's well understood that when
secondary Canon can't legally respond
a client and so these are the things I'm
aware of that would have to be fixed in
this system tor added complexity and
chitchat to make it have strong
consistency and you're actually the way
I got that list was by thinking about
the labs you're gonna end up doing all
the things I just talked about as part
of labs two and three to build a
strictly consistent system okay so let
me spend one minute on there's actually
I have a link in the notes to a sort of
retrospective interview about how well
GFS played out over the first five or
ten years of his life at Google so the
high-level summary is that the most is
that was tremendously successful and
many many Google applications used it in
a number of Google infrastructure was
built as a late like big file for
example BigTable I mean was built as a
layer on top of GFS and MapReduce also
so widely used within Google may be the
most serious limitation is that there
was a single master and the master had
to have a table entry for every file in
every chunk and that men does the GFS
use grew and they're about more and more
files the master just ran out of memory
ran out of RAM to store the files and
you know you can put more RAM on but
there's limits to how much RAM a single
machine can have and so that was the
most of the most immediate problem
people ran into in addition the load on
a single master from thousands of
clients started to be too much in the
master kernel they see if you can only
process however many hundreds of
requests per second especially the right
things to disk and pretty soon there got
to be too many clients another problem
with a some applications found it hard
to deal with this kind of sort of odd
semantics and a final problem is that
the master that was not an automatic
story for master failover
in the original in the GFS paper as we
read it like required human intervention
to deal with a master that had sort of
permanently crashed and needs to be
replaced and that could take tens of
minutes or more I was just too long for
failure recovery for some applications
okay excellent I'll see you on Thursday
and we'll hear more about all these
themes over the semester